welcome to your weekly ticket well Black
Adam finally has a new star attached to
the film nois Antonio is set to star
alongside Dwayne Johnson in DC's Black
Adam santanaya will play atom smasher a
character who can control his molecular
structure with the ability to manipulate
his size strength and durability
meanwhile Dwayne Johnson will star as
the antihero Black Adam in his first
superhero role that's surprising Black
Adam focuses on the DC character that
was first created as the arch-nemesis
for the hero known as Shazam however the
character has evolved into a more
complex antihero and has become one of
DC's more prominent characters the
Warner Brothers film is set to be
released in theaters on December 22nd
2021 Jena Prince Blythewood is set to
direct the Tristar pictures film The
Woman King starring Academy
award-winning actress Viola Davis the
film is inspired by true events that
took place in the kingdom of Dahomey one
of the most powerful states of Africa in
the 18th and 19th centuries the woman
king tells the story of an army general
of an all-female military unit and her
daughter noe who together fight the
French and neighbouring tribes who
violated their honor and slave their
people and threatened to destroy
everything they've lived for and Mattel
and Universal are developing a
live-action movie based on the 90s hit
TV show wishbone lovely show the film
will be produced by Peter Farley with a
script by Roy Parker
wishbone originally aired on PBS from
1996 through 2001 and followed a Jack
Russell Terrier that performed famous
literary moments Mattel will be
rebooting the property into a modern
family-friendly comedy
all right today we will be highlighting
modern updates to classic literature
from our curated list on Fandango now
and here to help us with a
recommendation from that list is film
critic and a writer at the LA Times in
Tribune News Service Katie Walsh Katie
what do you think is a good
recommendation from this list hey Cale
well I gotta go with the number one
entry on this list which is clueless
from 1995 mostly because this movie is
imprinted on my soul I really do think
that it's one of the first movies that
made me become a movie fan it's one of
the first movies I remember anticipating
coming out I remember reading about it
and like a Seventeen magazine but it's
just so smart and funny and I love when
people find out that it is based on Emma
because it feels like such a movie of
its time of the mid-90s and it feels
like so like Geist II and it really
captures something about teen culture at
that time but it's based on this Jane
Austen book from the 19th century and I
think it really preserves the story and
spirit of the book but it also has all
this great modern language and Amy
Heckerling the writer director just did
such a great job of like capturing the
slang and even popularizing some slang
and you know I love when they do a
modern update of a classic that is
actually feels like it's of this world
but it's like based on that story I
think it holds up and it's just like a
wonderful rewatch I mean I I just think
I could rewatch this movie every year
and be happy yeah absolutely I had no
idea I had no idea until this list came
out that it was like literature so what
do you think makes classic literature
perfect for like a teen movie well you
know a certain set especially the Jane
Austen stuff and I think like some
Shakespeare stories as well like they
they have such heightened emotions and
when you're a teen you're going through
a lot everything is high stakes you know
the relationships between you and your
crush or you and your friends you and
your family like it all seems like
everything is a huge deal so I think
that you know a lot of these stories
that are coming of age stories and
hero's journey stories with like a lot
of emotions and things going on like
really translate to a team coming-of-age
movie or just like a teen culture movie
and I also just think that there's a lot
of fun like side characters that you can
get in in the teen movie especially in
like the Shakespeare adaptations or even
the Austen adaptations there's so many
fun characters that are around that that
led for a really fun story I also just
want to say about the 2020 Emma which is
really fun and you should do this the
one that stars anya taylor joy directed
by autumn duelled
you can basically quote clueless along
with that movie like there's a great
moment where you can just go I love Josh
you can totally like map the two movies
together I highly recommend this oh my
god that's so real yeah it's crazy so is
there any piece of literature deep that
you think should be kind of given that
teen movie like adaptation sort of feel
you know I would love to see a Midsummer
Night's Dream by Shakespeare done in
this style
I was looking this up and a couple years
ago they did a Midsummer Night's Dream
with adult cast and they did all
Shakespearean language and I'm kind of
like I think it's cool when they do a
Shakespearean language update but I
would much rather see like a cool like
euphoria style Midsummer Night's Dream
like yeah actually feels modern and like
of this world and like edgy because that
piece of literature at that time was
edgy and interesting and and cool and so
it's like okay let's like actually bring
this into the modern world and use the
low language that teens would actually
use so I think there's still an
opportunity to to make a Midsummer
Night's Dream really cool teen movie so
yeah we gotta get the Sam Levenson on
that I want to leave India as puck like
causing trouble among all the teens like
that would be amazing yeah absolutely
all right well thank you so much for
your suggestion and your expertise make
sure to check out Katie Walsh on her
personal account which is Katie Walsh
STX yes great talking to you
and because here on weekly ticket we
like to make sure that you're covered
here are two more pics from that list
that are definitely worth a watch or a
rewatch if maybe you didn't know some of
these were based on classic literature I
didn't know half of them were first up
is the will blood team comedy easy a let
me just begin by saying that there are
two sides to every story and this is my
side the right one
the reimagining of Nathaniel Hawthorne's
The Scarlet Letter is a contemporary
high school comedy that tells the story
of a scheming student who plots to give
her popularity a boost by painting
herself the most promiscuous girl in
school prompted by her popular best
friend to spill details of her boring
weekend olive played by Emma Stone a
clean-cut teen decides to spice things
up by telling a little lie about losing
her virginity when the high school
busybody played by Amanda Bynes
overhears the conversation and spreads
it all over campus Olive suddenly
becomes notorious for all the wrong
reasons
but if you're looking for a drama check
out oh and I'm very proud to say this
publicly I love him like my own son the
classic tale of Shakespeare's Othello is
told from the basketball court in this
high school drama the film focuses on
Odin played by Mekhi Phifer who is the
only black student at an elite private
school and dreams of playing in the NBA
when his best friend Hugo played by Josh
Hartnett becomes jealous of all the
attention he's receiving from his
basketball coach dad played by Martin
Sheen he convinces him that his
girlfriend is cheating on him with
another member of the basketball team as
the basketball season comes to a
dramatic finish conflict among the
friends escalates into tragedy all right
well that's it for today make sure to
check out the full list of 37 modern
updates to classic literature we'll
leave a link below and make sure to
leave a comment and let us know which
one is your favorite I'm Kayla and I'll
see you next time